instant kad merad sera avec nous les
cherry et on en un quart d'heure son
fils s'ils ont mis la legal d'ananas les
caméras ne sont pas du cadre
il croit extradé elmaleh qui attendent
héros météo mai de la photo que vous
venez de m remettez fois vous avez
fédérer s'est pas calmée et ça c'est
très grave
je vais leur faire une dernière fois et
mignon sur la tête de ma mère si vous
mettez la photo de gad elmaleh je viens
origine et vous ça je vais voir ta vie
on voit sa justice quinté dans un
instant va recevoir kad merad
[Applaudissements]
mais ça il met sa lepi pétards il fait
ça qui fait ça qui est on voit les
fautes et les mecs non sans rigoler qui
envoie les qui envoie les photos y
envoyer photos c'est je me souvins non
c'est moi kad merad et avec tous
[Applaudissements]
regardez comme on dit et on recommence